welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how one
division's real
tv influences are not classic sitcoms
but the scariest
tv show episodes and movies that have
sent us down conspiracy rabbit holes in
our lives but you know not too deep
because in the good old days conspiracy
theories were just like fun
and they didn't lead us to storm
government buildings i'm eric voss
talking tv today with hector navarro
hey buddy hello eric and happy mefesto
to you
thanks for having me on the show and a
happy mephisto to you
you know i i think the last time we had
you on big question it was to talk about
what version of time travel tenant is
going to be we kind of need your brain
to
answer these hard hard questions because
none of us know what's going on in
monovision well it's funny because tenet
the time travel device ended up being um
pretentious so that was the main use of
time travel in that film
uh you know to varying degrees for
different uh audience members so
that yeah i guess we were all wrong or
were we i don't know
type nine pretentious or type 10
confusing
our big question eric is what the hell
is going on
in wanda vision and what movies and tv
shows
can we watch to help us understand what
is going on in one division ah
yes yes on the surface one division
seems to be borrowing from things like
the dick van dyke show bewitched the
brady bunch
and others but if you never watch a
single episode of those shows don't
worry
you're fine because beneath the surface
wanda vision is
horror uh wanda is trapped in a delusion
of her own making we think
uh she's using these sitcom tropes to
mask the darkness that is really
happening so really
the true reference points for one
division are those in the genres of
horror
and sci-fi and fantasy simulated reality
things that hector and i have spent our
entire lives talking about endlessly
in conversations that are about other
things but in this episode hector and i
are going to curate an essential viewing
watch list for one division
that you can try out between episodes
watch these things and i
promise you wanna vision will start to
make a lot more sense maybe even be a
bit more enjoyable to you
and hector our first title that we're
gonna talk about is the truman show
oh classic love it love harry 1998 movie
that started a lot of conspiracy
thinking and people in the late 90s
it's about this guy truman who his whole
life is a is like a tv show he lives in
this
simulated bubble that's broadcast to the
world without him
knowing and yeah we definitely see how
this is similar to what wanda vision
seems to be right she's in this sitcom
world but it's uh
it's false it's ersatz everything's fake
that's that's what i loved about
the truman show when it came out i think
it's a movie that's still ahead of its
time
but i i loved how when you brought this
up as an example
you can talk about how the truman show
had that old
sort of 1950s you know uh make america
great again
era of the united states almost this
this very idyllic
sitcom style style as opposed to
they could have just done it and had it
set in 1998 and had everything look like
1998 except that he just didn't know
there were hidden cameras and stuff but
i think that was a purposeful thing that
that film tried to do
to really get you to understand that
something was not right
and that a lot of the times when we look
back on those kinds of eras of
television or
american history or whatever that there
was stuff kind of under the surface that
wasn't all the way quite right so it's a
great example love the truman show and
the weight connects to wanda vision
nicely done and you're talking about
this whole nostalgic element to it and
starting there which is how wanavision
starts
kind of immediately triggers to the
viewer that
something is false about this because
while we both have uh we have a
nostalgic connection to the dick van
dyke show
we now view it as something that's kind
of showy it's it's a multi-cam
set it seems kind of fake everyone's
playing things up
and it's almost a little creepy now
because a lot of other things we're
going to talk about in this episode
have kind of trained our minds to view
this as suspect
as hiding something and the show almost
doesn't need
that um that scene at the end of the
episode of episode one where you see a
video control booth though i think for
viewers it's good to have that
you do have that in the truman show you
have the moon it's kind of their
control station and there's this other
thing and let me know if you agree with
this hector
in one division after episode two
there's this whole thing of for the
[Applause]
children
and then we see that manifest in episode
three when rapidly
she gets pregnant and has those babies
billy and tommy improving some of our
theories by the way but
in the truman show there it seems to be
kind of this weird
subplot that they don't mention a whole
lot but there's kind of this hint that
they want truman to have a kid
so that they can continue the series
after him kill him off if they need to
and just keep this going forever
it's super creepy they don't go too much
into it but that's part of the reason
they feel threatened by him
dating this other woman who they can't
control that's a great observation i
think
it's also in the movie the truman show
it's it's a great metaphor for like
if you feel a certain way about your
life and you want to go do stuff but
then when you have kids you have those
responsibilities so you do kind of have
to settle down
in a way so with truman's whole
character being like i think i want to
go explore be an explorer i want to get
out of this
small town i think that the pressure
that the producers of that tv show
put on his wife who was an actor even
to like have a kid with him and get
pregnant it's just just to get him to
really stop
questioning the world in a way and to
and to settle in and look at those
responsibilities
so i wonder if one division is going to
do something like that that's very
interesting or if i'm hoping one
division does something where
it really is wanda who wanted to have
these kids kind of like in the
comics you know what i mean it was it
was her who decided to have these kids
and she wasn't being manipulated by
anybody else and
there wasn't any ulterior motive but
then later bad stuff happens bad real
bad stuff happens bad stuff happens
to poor scarlet witch in the comics it's
never
a happy ending for her it seems like
i would say that the big difference
between the truman show and one division
is the amount of control that
that the protagonist has over their
world like yeah and the truman show it's
all kristoff it's ed harris's character
he controls the weather he controls
everything
but in one division it looks like sword
the people in the booth are not
really that much in control of west view
they're kind of following wanda's lead
or following the lead of whoever's doing
this to wanda
and that level of control is also kind
of the difference and the other
the next title we're gonna talk about
the matrix you know this series that's
where all of reality is a simulated mind
prison projected in the minds of humans
that are actually being
farmed in these pods as batteries for
machines
and a similar kind of idea right um it's
much bigger in scope
all of reality versus like a small west
view town different aesthetic
less sakami more like grungy cyberpunk
you're a breathtaking
but i think basically the point of view
of cipher
in the matrix is wanda in one division
he prefers to live in the lie to live in
the simulation
because that makes him happier as like
and it seems like wanda could say
ignorance is bliss
i think we're going to get in one
division the heartbreaking revelation as
to
why wander put herself into the
situation and like you said i think
it'll be
something similar to we understood joey
pentaliano's motivation we understood
cypher
you know that movie set that up so
brilliantly in the world of the matrix
to be like
actually yeah would you want to be able
to eat steak or would you want to eat
some goop
you know with no hair in a in a ship
called the nebuchadnezzar
but you're free that's it's a great you
know sort of uh
metaphysical dilemma but i think we're
gonna get the revelation in this
in this mini series where where we're
gonna learn wanda has been
really dealing with the death of vision
the man
whom she loved the synthazoid whom she
loved uh i bet it's gonna be
heartbreaking but um yeah that's like
that's like the key difference and
although you know in the same way that
like neo was able to bend or break the
rules
it's it kind of gets a little bit closer
to wanda being able to be like
nope and things can just kind of
rearrange and stuff so now
if we want to talk about um the
possibility that wanda could be a
villain of this we should look at the
twilight zone
season three episode eight a classic
it's a good life
so one of my favorite episodes one of
the creepiest ones that's where it's a
six-year-old boy anthony fremont he
controls this isolated town in ohio with
his mind
all of his neighbors just have to play
along with him because he can look into
their thoughts and
they always have to smile and just play
along and then he banishes them to a
hellish cornfield if they don't do what
he wants
and then at the end he turns a guy into
a jack in a box it's super creepy
it's very creepy and then the simpsons
did it yeah the simpsons done everything
already who cares
in uh their third season the second ever
treehouse of horror
and instead of uh it being called it's a
good life i think
they named the segment the bart zone
like the twilight zone
same thing he turns homer into a
jack-in-the-box same exact premise
except the nightmare there is that he
actually bonds with his father and then
bart had to wake up after they had like
spent some time together and loved each
other
but that's that's usually my entry point
to most pop culture things is that i
just watched the simpsons growing up but
they would tell us my aging throughout
my life has been just one after the
other realizing what simpson's jokes
were referring to
yeah oh citizen kane oh okay i get it
now yeah this is a heartbreaking one
though because you you mentioned
uh before we started talking about it
the possibility that wanda could be the
villain
and that bums me out but especially
after episode three eric
especially after episode three i was
like oh no no no no no
it may be this way this this is where we
might be going so this is a great
example to get that that that feeling
that sense of
when wanda asks geraldine to leave it
it had this twilight zone feeling of
like oh oh you have just
just that banishment i'm just blasting
you out it felt like what anthony
fremont would do
and to me it was the toy helicopter and
it's only because i have this theory
that that helicopter is the sword
helicopter that just got turned into a
toy but
if you can turn something in real life
into a toy that's scary as hell that's a
jack of the box that's a homer jack in
the box it's very scary
not nodding it's the air conditioning we
see a similar thing
in our next title black mirror which is
basically a not as good
modern version of the twilight zone
dealing with more
technology but there are a bunch of
great episodes of it including the uss
callister which is just like it's a good
life but it's done with a game developer
where he traps the minds of his
co-workers in his digital dollhouse it's
all based on like a star trek
kind of show and it's all about toxic
fandom that uss callister
such a great episode maybe my favorite
episode of black mirror because i'm a
big trekkie
my favorite episode was san junipero
just because it's one of the few
episodes where characters just don't get
unreasonably horribly punished for
not really doing anything wrong it's
just such a sweet love story about
um these lovers who meet in a digital
afterlife i should say spoiler warning
these shows have been out for like
several years now um we'll put a spoiler
warning at the top of the episode
hang the dj uses a similar one that was
from the same season
uh as uss callister that's where couples
are pairing
and they start off the relationship
knowing when the relationship's going to
expire
but then it's eventually revealed that
all these couples are just simulations
within a dating app
algorithm it has a san junipero kind of
feel to it not as good as san junipero
but all of these kind of parallel what's
going on in one division right it's it
seems like a digital world
that is not real where characters are
trapped there to serve some other kind
of deeper purpose
i had never before this show considered
wanda maximoff's powers of reality
manipulation
as being something that kind of has like
a digital motif and then watching the
show
all of these theories coming out about
like well it could be her it could all
be her because maybe
like a lot of people around the world
they grew up on american television
and maybe that's how this stuff is kind
of being funneled so in the same way
that like
black mirror uses technology as the sort
of framing device and it doesn't seem
crazy you can watch one division and and
i there may be a revelation of like
why tv though why why all of this tv
history how does wanda know about this
stuff
maybe they had reruns in sokovia that's
what it comes down to you know what i
mean maybe they had reruns of dick van
dyke and bewitched and brady bunch in
sokovia
[Music]
it could be something as simple as like
um she's strapped down
somewhere and then on the tv is some
kind of like tv land or some kind of
network that's playing reruns
and then so that's just kind of what is
filtering into
her mind in the same way that an
inception when you listen to music
uh that kind of filters down to the
dream layer underneath but what a
convenient tv marathon that's on that it
starts in the
50s and goes through each decade like
and chronological
marijuana very convenient um
now a show that i think if you are a bit
too confused by one division and want to
feel a bit more confused
um watch legion on fx very weird show
season one i loved the pre seasons after
that
kind of lost me a little bit but legion
is all about
uh the character legion david holler he
is a marvel mutant exactly like one
division is but if you were to watch
this show you would not think
that you're watching a superhero thing
it seems like you're watching kind of a
trippy
exploration of mental illness or
dissociative identity disorder maybe but
it's a very similar concept
it's an institutional one flew over the
cuckoo's nest kind of thing but he ends
up working with like this team of
mutants and he is stalked this whole
time by this creepy demonic entity
that is called the devil with the yellow
eyes one of the most terrifying
characters in tv
is that the shadow king or is that a
different character it is revealed to be
the shadow king aka spoiler i i got a
question for you eric i got a question
for you because i've only seen the first
episode of legion
and i was very impressed and i need to
go back and and do the entire series
is there a definitive connection to the
x-men movie franchise
is there yes there is um at
towards the end of season one i want to
say episode seven
they go into david holler's backstory
and how he is
the son of charles xavier and there is a
flashback at one point where he sees
a wheelchair rolling in and it is the
charles xavier
uh patrick stewart x wheelchair
you don't see patrick stewart but you
see the wheel it's very exciting
and what's the reason i bring this up is
like wanda
is the daughter of magneto these people
are the second generation they're both
omega-level mutants it's not
similar powers wanda can rewrite reality
with sorcery
legion has a bunch of different
identities um
stored in his mind that all kind of take
over in different ways
one of them is shadow king and that's
how he has that connection
but think of it this way if you know our
theories are right and if mephisto
or the grim reaper or one of these other
demonic entities
is stalking wanda that is very very very
similar to what we saw in legion and
they both bend
genres they both have like not
necessarily sit kami episodes in legion
but they do have like musicals
uh they do like a black and white kind
of weird avant-garde
movie episode so if you want like an
even darker
more violent version of one division
definitely check out legion yeah legion
definitely pushes the style
of what people would come to expect from
the even the x-men movies
even with stuff like deadpool and logan
kind of pushing that style already
that's what was so impressive about the
tv show legion and it looks like that is
what one division is doing now which is
cool it's it has a
that same kind of feeling of what am i
watching what exactly is going on i need
to go to youtube and find one of these
nerds to explain
it to me where's the x-men but where's
the avengers i don't
know i don't get it yeah what is this
now another title we should acknowledge
is pleasantville
uh starring peter parker and reese
witherspoon
pizza time they get sucked into this 50s
sitcom reality that
gradually changes technicolor to
represent more
free thinking views taking over that
decade
there are some similar themes of using
tv
as the framing device um of the
community versus the individual
and everyone's kind of smiling everyone
being like what the hell is going on and
using technicolor within a black and
white frame to represent
reality warping um but beyond those
aesthetics i'm not sure how much
pleasantville is gonna connect to
wandavision no but i mean
look we gotta we gotta mention it
because it's definitely i feel like
influential to even just the black and
white to the color
because at the end of episode two it
felt like wanda and viz
made that move almost as if it was like
an evolution in their own lives
something that sort of opened up
something had you know shifted and
that's how it's used in pleasantville
which is really interesting is that
people
once they sort of are able to break out
of that mold of
more cookie-cutter conformity of the
1950s or whatever
whether it's like sexually or with
social issues whatever it was
people would start walking around and
they would be in color right once they
had sex they would be in color once they
which is great you know what's fun in
pleasantville if i remember correctly
there was kind of the sub theme
of the red scare yes uh that was a big
part of it of like oh they
they changed color to represent free
thinking progressive views
but in the 50s people were so
anti-communist because you know of
all the propaganda and the way society
was warped during the cold war
and that seems to be a little
undercurrent in one division at least
the first two episodes
i know mr hearts we don't break bread
with bolsheviks
and visions saying norm's a communist
like that was part of the time
but i i don't remember classic sitcoms
mentioning communism a whole lot because
all those tv writers were terrified of
being labeled as communists they would
have lost their careers
oh yeah and i'm reading a bunch of old
marvel comics right now all they do is
fight communists it's hilarious it's
really the most political propaganda
you know thing that i've ever seen but
it's just iron man and hulk and all
these characters fighting
communists and what people thought of of
this political
group back then uh during the cold war
it's really really funny but yeah that
was a great little moment in episode two
i felt really creeped out by that and
then the reaction and then the joking
and then
i i thought oh maybe maybe wandavision
is
giving us these little hints throughout
that uh it just felt so out of place
because like you said eric
old sitcoms would never talk about this
but which would never talk about this so
the fact that vision said that felt like
should i be watching this is this
appropriate
now if you're a huge bewitch fan and
there is an episode that deals with
communism don't at us i'm sorry we
didn't watch the shows it's just those
shows were not known for
bringing up the bolsheviks a lot please
at me i'm curious
i want to know i want to know what that
was not a nikita khrushchev cameo in the
brady bunch
[Music]
now we're going to talk about just real
quickly a couple things you should check
out uh if you
if you have time um first off just a
couple things that bend
genre the genre benders one and you can
watch this right after you're done with
this episode
too many cooks uh from adult swim it's
on youtube now i love this uh this is
just a late night short
that they put it's not sure it's like 14
minutes but it's uh it's like a classic
80s sitcom intro sequence but it never
ends it just keeps going and going and
going until it devolves into this
meta nightmare and it's like meta on top
of meta on top of meta it's like four
different episodes rick and morty
stacked on top of itself oh man
but when i watched wandavision i felt
like oh this is too many cooks there's
like a creepy
sinister force at work here just
thinking about too many cooks right now
i hate it
but i know that when i actually am in
the middle of watching it i love it it
really
it really runs the gamut it takes me up
and down through i'm like
no this is stressing me out this
stresses me out too this is hilarious
and genius and brilliant and i love it
and
i never want it to end so
yeah around that same time um or maybe
it was a couple years after this
there's mr robot i watched the first two
seasons of mr robot
really liked it um it's starting to get
away from me but there's an episode
four of season two where elliot sees his
reality as a tgif style sitcom alf
is in it which is great um but it felt
like the writers that episode saw too
many cooks it was around this time in
the middle of the last decade where
people became very self-aware
of of sitcoms stuff and a lot of sketch
comedy you would see this too
bills bills and more bills
and i feel like that started to inform
what one division now is absolutely
i'm surprised that it took alpha this
long he's tried to come back so many
times in pog form
on mr robot when are we getting that big
elf movie that's the thing that's really
going to help him break through
again to the mainstream you know or not
another subcategory of things you should
check out you've probably seen a lot of
these we just want to connect them
these kind of movies where they're all
kind of simulated reality or it was all
a dream
things going back to the classic the
wizard of oz i understood that reference
i understood that reference error
okay uh we are going to find uh i think
a lot of parallels to the wizard of oz
oh we have two witches you have a tin
man
uh in episode three there's a movie
theater marquis showing oz the great and
powerful
which is weirdly a 2013 movie in a 70s
sitcom
world but really the deeper theme of the
wizard of oz is
everything is a con everything's for the
show
it's all kind of a lie the wizard is
just a man behind the curtain pay no
attention to that man
and the wizard of oz is a big part of
lost there's a lot of references to the
wizard of oz and lost as well yeah in
the same way i think
it's worth rewatching the wizard of oz
any day of the week because it's a it's
a great classic
but i think you're going to see a lot of
parallels between this show and that
movie
absolutely yeah i got to get that i got
they have a wizard of oz in 3d
on 3d blu-ray i got to buy that because
i have a 3d tv so you don't
that's crazy yeah it's the coolest thing
ever i have yet to see the wizard of oz
in 3d
but i need to track down that blu-ray
and uh and enjoy that because i'm sure
that that
just enhances how crazy and trippy and
perfect that movie is so yeah once this
is all over eric you can come over and
watch a 3d movie once we're all safe and
in the clear
i got all the marvel movies in 3d i got
moana
listen bunch of them we have blueberry
raspberry ginseng sleepy time green tea
with lemon blueberry chamomile vanilla
walnut constant comment and
earl grey did you make some of those up
now we mentioned inception before
i assume however many times you see an
inception that's as many times as you
need to have seen inception
yeah there are parallels here there's
the descartes dream argument
you know it seems like the characters
might be inside a collapsing dream i do
like the idea that it seems like a
monovision they're using these small
objects as totems the way like uh agnes
has her pendant
really i would say instead of
re-watching inception re-watch the
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
i think that is gonna be way more
similar because we know from trailer
footage that wanda and vision are it
seems like they're gonna fight back
against this collapsing reality that's
what eternal sunshine is it's this
doomed couple
who are you know they're heartbroken and
they're trying to erase their memories
of painful memories
the way wanda appears to be doing but
they kind of
run uh out the clock away from their
memories as things are fading around
them
and it kind of seems like what's going
on in one division right this is a
doomed couple they don't have a future
and they're
trying to cling to their past i feel
like inception and eternal sunshine both
have
at their center gui center of the story
it's a story
about a failed relationship in a way but
eternal sunshine feels you just
feel it much much more yeah you know i
think inception uh sacrifices a little
bit of that for the amazing spectacle
all the cool buildings and everything
whereas eternal sunshine's like no we're
really gonna make you
think like you are jim carrey and kate
winslet and it's
depressing and it's bleak and we've all
been there and
enjoy this movie it's really sad but
really really great
and uh great parallel to one division
but i'm hoping
man i don't know i want a great
heartbreaking tragedy that moves me
and is kind of true to these characters
in the comic books but i also want
everybody to have the happiest ending
in the ncu i'm i'm a terrible fan
because i just want everybody to be
super happy all the time and then i'm
like great that's great what's this
movie they're having a picnic
great i wish that i could bake a cake
made out of rainbows and smiles and we'd
all eat
be happy she doesn't even go here i'll
take it
you know i think all i really want from
these characters is humanity which
i know visions it's hard to ask that but
paul bettany i've never loved vision
more than when i'm watching this show
finally finally you've come around
you've come around and you're kind of
like
vision and i think it's i get to see how
good of an actor paul but which i've
always liked paul bettany i loved him as
jarvis i loved him in his other roles
now you really get to see what these
actors can do
give them more than just a subplot and
an avengers team-up movie and see what
they can do and this is what we're
getting it's
so great to see them uh have like
a real human experience of just trying
to
have their dream life together and you
know at the end of it they're probably
not gonna be able to keep it
one more simulated reality thing there's
a lot of these movies right there's like
source code there's dark city there's a
13th floor
if you are a big x-files fan go back and
watch kill switch
because they feature that same song that
was in the first trailer the platters
it's twilight time
i know that marvel must have pulled it
from that episode of kill switch the
fact that
sword is their sword feels like an
x-files type entity
fbi division i feel like there's going
to be some x-files uh dna
in the show the final category we're
going to talk about because i think it's
pretty easy for a lot of fans of these
different genres to see the technical
aspects and how they parallel
i think the true meaning of the show is
going to be found in the actor's
performance catherine han
what a talent she can deliver things so
precisely like a scalpel
to where it's like yeah um i i got the
pleasure of meeting her when i first
moved out to hollywood and she was so
so nice and it's so rare to have a
real-life celebrity
who is actually nice and sweet to you
and she was like getting ready
in the green room of our improv theater
for a show i didn't know she was in
there i was just like oh
um yeah we'll be ready in two minutes
she's like great thank you so much like
was so kind to me in this shitty improv
theater
and i'll never forget it so i'm so happy
that she's on this yeah i am a
massive catherine han fan and i had a
chance to interview her for one division
and i asked her to i was like would you
ever play
uh olivia octavius in live action and
she was like oh yeah totally and i was
like
great confirmed you're the next
spider-man thanks
you just gave me that but she was the
nicest exactly but it always feels like
because i'm such a big fan of comedy
that whenever like
comedy people kind of get to be in these
big worlds and these big franchises and
stuff it just makes it
all the better and what you were saying
about her performance is she can be so
precisely funny in wanda vision and then
something happens when reality breaks or
whatever
and it's the most terrifying and just
you know all your hairs are standing up
in the back your neck because of her
selling it right so to help us
understand those kind of human tics
we have to watch a couple cult horror
films
one that a lot of you are pointing out
is get out jordan peele's amazing film
where daniel kalia gets lured into this
like
racist upstate new york society that
wants to snatch his body
and those of other young black people
for their minds of these weird creepy
aging sick white people
and the big similar parallel point is uh
deborah joe ruff's great uh mental
breakdown which is just like stop it
stop it and it's just like you know the
the house
made of of get out where she has a
similar moment she's just like crying
but it's not like no no no no no no no
yeah amazing amazing very similar and
you see how when everyone in the room is
smiling there is something wrong
no one ever lives their life that way
another similar reference point happened
in the woods
so cabin in the woods drew goddard movie
uh he's the guy who directed the pilot
of the
good place and he worked on buffy
and he was gonna do the sinister six
movie after amazing spider-man 2.
it was going to do an x-force movie too
it got scrapped anyway
uh this movie seems like a horror film
it's pretty stereotypical group of fans
fall into a horror scenario but it's all
revealed
to be this elaborate lab experiment run
by
um also bradley whitford from get out
isn't that and
it's all about creating these scenarios
to
uh give human sacrifices to these
ancient
demons to keep them satisfied so they
won't destroy the world
it's insane and amazing also stars a
young
thor yes chris simsworth isn't that uh i
think this came out
after he was cast as thor but before
thor had come out
so definitely watch this one has a lot
of similar wanna vision stuff right you
have the whole thing
of uh people in a video booth watching
the horror unfold
and there's a sense that they're getting
something else out of it well we're
talking about cult stuff
there's a bunch of classics there's
wicker man there's more recent one
mitsumar
very similar kind of thing people go to
this rural community and it's all about
human sacrifice we kind of know where
it's going
again when people are smiling and
singing there's something wrong
but there is one cult title that i think
is more important maybe than any other
title on this list that everyone should
watch
martha marcy mae marlene did he see this
movie i i have not no tell me about it
okay so this was elizabeth
olsen's breakout role i think this led
directly to her getting cast in the mcu
uh she plays occult escapee and she goes
by many different names
marcie may is the name she's given by
the cult leader and it's all shown in
flashback
but this movie is terrifying um
because the whole movie it seems very
very grounded but
she keeps getting the sense that she has
not fully escaped the cult
and she keeps seeing familiar people
standing across the lake
that are just watching her and she looks
back and they're gone
uh and the way the movie ends i won't
spoil it but has such a chilling
open-ended ending when you watch this
movie
and then you watch one division you're
like this is why
she is cast as scarlet witch kevin feige
knew from the beginning that she
was going to be in a role at some point
the mcu where she's going to be in a
reality and she's not sure what's going
on
but everyone around her smiling and
telling her things are okay
and i mean i'm just gonna say all four
of those names begin with the letter
m right wait what are the names again
martha marcy mayweather why did you say
that name
but why did you say that name why would
you say that name why did you say that
name
what is your son
[Laughter]
say that name like why but like why
would you say it
why that synopsis that what you
described to me it reminded me of a
movie that kind of traumatized me as a
young
person as a kid when it came out
starring
ant-man michael douglas the game was
another kind of a real mind
movie where you're like yeah what's real
and what's not
i haven't seen it in years i haven't
revisited in years but i still know that
feeling
of when i first saw it and i've been
meaning to check it out yeah david
fincher so that might be another one in
those same kind of conversations of like
the the the character the protagonist
not the tenant protagonist but like the
protagonist of whatever movie we're
talking about
doesn't know what's real and what's not
sometimes those
those mind trip movies are just so much
fun man and stressful
and stressful so hector i want to know
what you think but for me
of this list the ones you should watch
watch that twilight zone episode
uh watch a couple episodes of legion and
watch
martha marcy may marlene and you're
covered you know you've seen wizard of
oz
you've seen the matrix you might have
seen the truman show so you're kind of
covered there you know what those are
all about you might not know these other
titles though
definitely give those a shot i i
guarantee you
wanna vision's gonna start to make a lot
more sense i agree with that
100 and i think maybe the only other one
i would throw in there in case somebody
you know we got a lot of young people
still discovering classic movies every
single year if you're watching this and
you haven't seen it
i would say also the truman show i've
been getting a lot of truman show vibes
especially with the first few episodes
of wanda vision i think that's a classic
but
martha marcy may marlene i need to check
it out and let us know what other
parallels you see uh in the comments
below this is an evolving process so
we've seen three episodes so far we'll
see what four five six seven eight nine
have in store for us
but before we continue with this episode
because uh hector's gonna answer some
questions for us uh we wanna thank some
friends who helped us make it
uh our sponsor mint mobile for lots of
us saving money
is the top of our new year's resolution
list right
so if you're still paying insane amounts
of money every month for wireless
what are you doing i just got
overcharged on my current plan i'm not
gonna shout them out but
like i went slightly over and now it's
like great i'm paying 30 more dollars
this month that
sucks um just because i didn't realize
my phone wasn't connected to wi-fi
here's what you do though you switch to
mint mobile it's really the easiest way
to save this year as the first company
to sell premium wireless service online
only
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings with plans starting at just
15 a month which sounds insane
to pay that low for your monthly cell
phone bill but it's possible with mobile
it's normally tough to make more money
or to save extra money but mobile makes
it super simple by going online only and
limiting all those traditional costs in
retail
mobile passes significant savings on to
you and
all plans come with an unlimited talk
and unlimited text
and high-speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network i feel like
that's what i need
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan and keep your same phone number
with all your contacts
and if you're not 100 satisfied mint
mobile has you covered with their 7 day
money back guarantee to switch to mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 a month to get your
new wireless plan for just 15 bucks a
month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free
go to mintmobile.com big q that's mint
mobile.com
bigq cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com
big q we also want to thank our friends
at imperfect foods for sponsoring this
video
see folks every year billions of pounds
of food go to waste
and it's often because it just doesn't
live up to those strict cosmetic
standards of grocery stores
imperfect foods is on a mission to
reimagine grocery delivery for a kinder
less wasteful world isn't that what we
need they deliver
sustainable affordable groceries
including produce quality protein eggs
and dairy and pantry staples straight to
your door
plus they're always adding fun and
tasting new discoveries for you to try
each week
all you have to do to sign up is create
your flexible personalized grocery plan
and then shop online each week and get
affordable and sustainable groceries
delivered directly to your door
with imperfect foods grocery shopping
fits seamlessly into your life and every
week is a tasty adventure sign up with
imperfect foods today to save time save
money and save food from going to waste
and right now imperfect foods is
offering our listeners 20
off plus free shipping on your first
order when you go to imperfectfoods.com
and make sure to use the promo code big
questions so
they know that we sent you try imperfect
foods now for a limited time and get 20
off plus free shipping on your first
order go to imperfectfoods.com and use
big question to sign up that's 20 off
plus free shipping at imperfectfoods.com
offer code big question all right hector
is going to answer a couple bite-sized
questions for us
uh you ready hector i'm ready all right
let's do this uh first one comes from
our buddy civilian on discord who asks
if cable is in deadpool 3 is that the
first instance of an actor playing two
different roles
in the mcu absolutely not wrong sir
wrong
i think i think eric can come up with a
bunch of great examples but i feel like
maybe i'm wrong i feel like the first
example of an actor playing different
roles in the mcu
is from actress laura haddock who played
an autograph seeker in captain america
the first avenger and then a few years
later played
peter quill's mom who was dying in the
hospital in the first guardians of the
galaxy but
through the magic of retcons now her
autograph secret character
has been now uh in like fan wikis and
stuff and maybe from marvel studios
officially themselves has now been
credited as peter quill's grandmother
which is amazing so she played peter
quill's grandmother in the 40s and she
was like
hi trying to get an autograph from
captain america and then years later
that same actress played
her own daughter and there was even an
older woman
sort of next to her bed as she was dying
in 1989
when peter quill was scooped up or 1889
when peter cooper gets their idiot
scooped up i think it was 88
89 was when michael douglas hang pym
came in and punched a guy
out and then quit shield i'm quitting
but with
fashion so in 1988 when he got scooped
up uh which is great and um
and there's a ton of other examples of
of actors playing maybe sort of minor
minor-ish roles for the most part but uh
eric hit us hit us with some come on i
know
yeah there's um there's well jimmy chan
is gonna be playing cersei and eternal
she played the cree soldier minerva
and captain marvel and then uh kenneth
choi did the same thing as uh the lore
haddock thing he played jim arita and
helen commandos and captain america the
first avenger and then
played his own grandson principal morita
in spider-man homecoming
and i i hope that those are instances
where like the actors are
like i hope that kenneth choi was just
hired to be in spider-man as the
principal
and somebody didn't know that he would
like and then he had to be like i was in
captain america
and then they were like oh great you're
your grandfather like i'm hoping but i
don't know probably not
maybe they're a little smarter than i'm
giving credit for over at marvel studios
casting which they're pretty good at
they're pretty good at casting you know
there is a bit of problematic [ __ ] going
on here when there are people of color
playing two different characters like
i'm wondering if some of the casting
department is like no one's gonna know
i mean so i mean it's it's gemma chan
it's kenneth choi uh mahershala alfred
woodard i mean yeah those are
but with mahershala and alfre they you
could say they were in the netflix
marvel they were on luke cage
and uh you know there's probably a bit
of a dividing line there with the mcu
um unless they're sure unless it's all
connected this name keeps coming up over
and over again
there's gonna be a weird conversation
where they have to fight
uh the same face who is blade who was
cornell stokes
it's not gonna make sense you've lost
your goddamn mind charlie
i guess you can make the argument that
uh cameos right so stan lee
has played several different characters
and it's not just himself every time he
played hugh hefner but
eric come on that rolls those roles have
also been retconned into being overall
one role which is the watcher informant
that's who stan
sure yeah exactly yeah you could say
that uh so a hugh hefner in the ria
in this reality is really a watcher
informant makes sense it makes sense
it makes perfect sense um though joe
russo has cameo
in pretty much all of the movies he's
directed he was the doctor
in the first or in winter soldier he was
dr brussard civil war
he was uh the guy in the support group
and end game all different characters
they're the same guy
unless that guy is a squirrel triplets
full-grown triplets men that's all
that's all it is and then of course if
they do retcon the fantastic four movies
in the mcu chris evans it's gonna have
some explaining to do
ladies oh boy then there's also uh
uh we can't forget foggy nelson john
favreau who also is happy hogan
but he was foggy and daredevil with ben
affleck so i mean
lots of fun stuff like that so to answer
your question no josh brolin would not
be the first
but if they do do that and bring in
cable then him
he might be one of the first major you
know roles that we're kind of really
focusing on
that the mcu hasn't really done before
so you know but they're
we're going to run out of actors before
we run out of marvel characters for
these people to play
all right uh another question here
actually socialist on discord asks
could natasha have picked up thor's
hammer it's a great question eric it's a
great question
question it makes me think of one of my
favorite scenes from avengers age of
ultron a lot of people love the scene
where they're all sitting around the
hammer and they're all kind of talking
crap to thor and jeremy renner's like
whatever man it's a scam
dude whosoever so holds a hammer can be
thor
and uh of course natasha romanov's like
that's not something i need to
i need to know which is this really nice
little character revelation
i'm leaning towards she could not have
picked up thor's hammer because
mor more so based on the rules of thor's
hammer versus
natasha's worthiness does that make
sense i feel like
yeah go into it i think i know where
you're going yeah i feel like thor's
hammer has a more specific
set of rules than just if he or she
is worthy whoever so is worthy shall
possess the power of thor
i feel like that's odin being a little
simplistic and i think that there's more
programming happening in mjolnir and i
think that natasha romanov
would not be able to lift it because i
feel like natasha as a character black
widow is a character
her whole character arc is about trying
to make up for
the fact that she was this hired killer
working for
one team and then switching over to the
good guys whatever but still killing
people when she's the good guys
versus if we talk about thor look thor
has killed
many many many more people like he said
in thor ragnarok he's lived for a
thousand years and he's killed almost
twice as many
beings you know him being the mighty
thor but i think that thor
at his heart believes himself to be and
i think he kind of is
like a good heroic person who saves
lives
who answers prayers of you know
when when the norse you know vikings and
stuff would pray to thor like
that's how he considers himself to be
and i think that there's a lot of
mjolnir that comes with um the like
one's own perception
which goes into hey how come steve
couldn't lift it well either he was
faking it and he could and he didn't
want to seem like
like a jerk to thor or a lot of people
point out the fact that at that point in
avengers age of ultron
he knew that bucky killed tony's parents
and didn't tell tony
so i think even steve himself had a
thing within his own heart where he's
like
uh i don't feel good about this i'm
lying to my friend
oh that's interesting i never heard that
take before but even though captain
america
in in his heroics has also killed people
and killed bad guys and everything it's
not
it doesn't just come down to taking
lives it comes down to
somebody's own perception of their
worthiness
i guess but who knows maybe i made all
that up what do you think no
it's i i like that uh take actor i mean
it's weird because worthiness can't just
be a willingness to lay down your own
life because lots of people do that
like are is every firefighter worthy
uh is every person who runs toward
and protects someone and jumps on a
grenade or runs into a burning building
they're not all capable picking up that
hammer or summoning them
um so you're right there is some kind of
extra element to it
i think there's something to and this is
going to sound trite but like
does the world need me to be worthy
right now
like the world needed thor to be worthy
in each of those moments the world
needed cat to be worthy and endgame to
save thor's life
like there's that sense of like is does
the moment call for this
and by natasha saying i don't need that
question answered i think it's just kind
of a line saying like the world never
needs me to lift the hammer so i'm not
ever going to be worried
and to back up your claims in the
amazing crossover event from the early
2000s jla avengers or avengers jla
superman needed to pick up the hammer
like the world needed superman
to wield captain america's shield and
pick up mjolnir at the same time
and it's one of the best yeah most
amazing comic book moments ever
but it's like you're saying the universe
needed superman clark kent to do that in
that moment so he did so he's worthy
yeah
it's a and there is like a um um a what
if comic right where black widow picks
up the hammer
it's like the age of ultron what if but
i mean
he hasn't picked up the hammer i mean
come on
come on i'm pretty sure aunt may did it
i'm pretty sure you know
dr doom did it who cares whatever yeah
uh
exactly so i think if i don't think
natasha needs it and
i think more importantly we don't need
natasha to wield it like i think in her
mind if she wanted to jump on a grenade
or if there were a dire moment i think
she can think of a couple other ways
that she could solve that problem uh
rather than picking up this ancient
asgardian hammer
all right uh hector we have time for one
mailbag question around we call
box scraps and
our question this week will each answer
this uh
have you ever been truman showed i.e
have you been tricked or gaslighted into
participating in something for which you
were not fully aware of its true purpose
ooh yes that's a great question
that's i have definitely gone with
friends up to some parties in the
hollywood hills
and you can't not think it's really
glamorous and cool
and exciting and stuff i was expecting
to see mountains of cocaine i never saw
any
but also i'm such i'm i know right it's
kind of it's kind of disappointing
when you when you move to los angeles
from another part of the country i mean
i just moved from san diego which is
still just like
an extension of it's all southern
california or whatever but it's still
very different
but um i but the other thing about me
too eric is that like i can go to
something like that
and then like be walking back to the car
with my friends after or something and
my friends will go did you see that
that was crazy and i'll be like what
what what i missed something and then i
get disappointed i didn't see some
insane like
yeah so-and-so was there or this
happened or there was a mountain of
cocaine i never saw it
and i was running down a mountain of
cocaine how did you miss that
i'm bad at parties is what i'm saying oh
me too and i think you have to be real
careful in la when you go to parties
because la parties you could very easily
go to one where it's like
this was not a party this was um an
opportunity
for someone or some kind of weird event
one comes to mind for me
um a couple years ago i got
invited to a party by a friend of mine
and she sent us all like this facebook
message being like
hey so i'm throwing a birthday party for
a friend it's at their house in in
sherman oaks
um be sure to arrive by this time
because you're not going to want to miss
there's certain like things that we're
doing and in my mind i was like
oh it's going to be like a murder
mystery party or a game night i love
stuff like that you know
um so i'm like do i need to come in
character or wear any costume they're
like no no
no it's just gonna be real fun you have
an opportunity to win stuff and i was
like
hmm and this was like a period where i
was i think going through some
depression i was like i haven't gotten
out uh in a while i should go to a party
um it was a big mistake um and this
friend
she's still a good friend of mine so i
don't want to call her out i get what
she was doing but we we go to it
and i knock on the door and it's someone
i know
it's like someone i know through improv
and i'm like oh hey dude
um happy birthday and he's like oh it's
not my birthday
i'm like but this is your house he's
like yeah i'm like what is this no one
was really there yet
except this other dude that i knew who
seemed to be
it was his birthday but i'm like so it's
your birthday and he's like
uh yeah yeah
like it was clear he had been told
things to say but didn't know if i was
in on something no and i almost left
right then and there except a couple
other friends showed up and
who were on this facebook message and
i'm like what is this and they're like
we don't really know but the party seems
like
they were still setting up stuff like
but what was really scary
is i kept seeing shuffling around
in like back bedrooms what i seemed to
be pas
they had like walkie-talkies and i was
like
what is going on and i was texting my
friend i was asking her like
where are you are you here like should i
go
and no response and then so more and
more people get to the party
and everyone's kind of confused and
we're just like you know
drinking the kool-aid and then it's
poison and we all died
uh no but there's like a knock at the
door and it's like a
cop and uh and but so we thought it was
being too loud but it was all
like the cop it was like what was gonna
be a stripper but instead of a stripper
the car
the cop was like we're gonna make this
party fun and then a bunch of
um people came in with cameras started
recording us
and it was part of a um like a youtube
social experiment to try to make a party
fun um that sounds
awful i just was not prepared for i
would have preferred just
my friend telling me hey you're gonna be
part of this i would have been like all
right you know
but i had been like lured into this
party
and i was not in a good mental place at
the time i seriously had an
anxiety attack uh and i rushed out of
the house i had to run around
through the backyard i jumped over
someone's bushes and i
like sprinted out of there it freaked me
out
please tell me that that made it into
the cut that i can see this on youtube
and there's footage of some guy running
in the way in the backyard
face blurred because i didn't sign a
release um
i it's one of those parties where it's
and there's been other times where
things like that have happened you know
friends shoot a short film and they're
like we need to do a party scene we're
all gonna party afterwards
and i've learned since just don't do
those because it's just a nightmare
and like i i met up with her later that
night and she
asked me pointedly like why did you
leave
and i was like um i wasn't feeling too
well
the whole thing kind of freaked me out i
wasn't really into it like i was
apologizing
and then like a year later i was hanging
out with her and her roommate
and like somehow the conversation
steered into
like her roommates saying hey um
remember that
party and then my friend was like turn
to that from
like that like as if i couldn't see it
oh no and it was clearly they had been
talking [ __ ] about me since then being
like hey remember when eric overreacted
to this harmless thing we were doing
like there was no understanding on their
part that that was a very
weird thing to do to your friends um
well if they're watching right now it
was weird
well uh be wary of that and uh if you
ever moved to l.a
just be prepared that you might walk
into a party that is not a party
um but one that you have to sign a
release afterwards um
and uh good advice that's good advice
how you are the star
of a tv show suddenly um and that is it
for this episode of big question on that
terrifying note
thank you to hector for joining me this
episode i feel like we figured out what
one division is
oh easily yeah it's all about it's a
prank youtube show is what one division
actually
is you'll see you'll see they'll reveal
it they'll reveal it
uh you can follow hector at hector
navarro um
and is there anything else you want to
plug hector yeah you can check out uh me
and my homies
on a youtube channel called heroes
reforged we are also talking about
wandavision and a bunch of other fun
stuff we looked at the
vision comic book and how it could have
related to the show
we are reading comics and talking about
movies and tv shows star wars marvel
all the stuff that you like so check
that out over at heroesreforged
on youtube and we'd really appreciate it
thanks for sure uh
and you can follow me at eavos fellow
new rockstars and be sure to send us
your big questions using the hashtag
bigquestion uh you can also join our
patreon discord server where
that's usually where i go to first
looking for questions uh subscribe to
this podcast speed give us a nice
reading review if you don't mind
uh and subscribe to the new rockstars
here on youtube hit that notification
bell and we'll see you next week bye bye
everybody
big q thank you thank you
big dick boy smoke chronic big
[Music]
you